that's a rarity to go to a roller
skating rink and find live music there
most other roller rinks have gone
digital but head to Southern California
and you'll find one of the last
remaining rinks to employ a live organ
player
[Music]
my name is Dominic Cangelosi and I own
the moonlight roller way I've been
playing roller skating music for 70
years there are only about 10 or 15
roller rink organist left in the country
in the 40s and 50s
most of the rinks around the country
used live organ music and then when
Elvis Presley and the Beatles all came
into the picture in the 50s and 60s most
of the rinks around the country faced
out the live organ to play recorded
music but not the moonlight roller way
Wednesday through Monday the moonlight
roller Way plays recorded music just
like most roller rinks but one day a
week Dominic gets to dust off his
Hammond organ and throw back to a
different time a Tuesdays I play from 8
o'clock till 10:30 the people that come
on Tuesday nights are mixed crowd a
number of the skaters are old-time
skaters in their 70s and 80s who like to
skate to the organ music this place is
special because it's been here for so
long it's a historical landmark people
have skated here through the years met
their boyfriends girlfriends here raised
a family bring their grandchildren and
it's something from the past and I just
want to hold on to at least one night a
week I love coming here I come every day
and I enjoyed my customers they
appreciate it and they like the music I
have no plans to stop playing the organ
I'll play it as long as I'm here
[Music]
[Music]